ce sera certainement un film de noël
pour les enfants arthur et les minimoys
raconte l'histoire d'un petit garçon de
10 ans qui entre dans un monde magique
habité par les créatures de 2 mm de haut
un univers féerique et drôle que luc
besson a décidé de raconter à la fois en
images réelles et de synthèse
la réalité est incarnés par mia farrow
en jeune grand mère
les réactions hier lors de
l'avant-première était à la mesure du
paris
marie-jo jouant frêle avec pas si tu vas
rejoindre nos frères les minimoys
bienvenue au pays des minimoys ces
créatures animées vont elles claire luc
besson et nerveux il joue gros
cinq ans de travail 65 millions d'euros
pour arthur et les minimoys
il accueille les voix françaises de ces
personnages marc lavoine mylène farmer à
la massonne tous des chanteurs parce que
dib et son fils adam là c'est leur voix
tandis que les people se succèdent dans
la foule on patiente comme on peut
regarder la mobilisation qui vont mettre
en avant première les besson a en effet
cédé 40 minutes de son film à un
opérateur téléphonique
chaque jour des séances de deux minutes
sont diffusés aux abonnés une stratégie
de communication pour éviter le piratage
de cette histoire qui plonge un petit
garçon nommé arthur dans un monde de
créatures féeriques est la princesse
rivière la fille du roi des minimoys
et magnifie les hommages selignac tout
le connais monde
je suis pas du tout dans le monde de
l'enfance mais je suis un adulte qui
respecte beaucoup l'enfant que j'étais
parce qu'il m'a appris beaucoup de
choses jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est
plutôt les les grands qui détruisent la
planète et pas vraiment les petits déjà
beaucoup de leçons à prendre le temps de
toujours des temps de détruire tout mon
univers et le mot au coeur du film la
nature et comment la protéger c'est pour
ses 55 besson écrit le film mais les
adultes ils retrouveront leur part
d'enfance ferry qu'angélique
mélancolique romantique y est c'est un
vrai voyage pour fonctionner enfants je
vais toucher de le voir 50 fois avec les
miens parce qu'il ya trop de trucs à
voir c'est la folie c'est largement
digne des plus grands films que font les
américains là je tire mon chapeau à lui
vu son personnage tueur maîtres toile en
sel des aliments
arthur est brave et son coeur est pur il
t'accompagnera si telle est votre
souhait qu avant
réussi